fut un temps où une visite du prince
charles soulevait les foules au canada
peut-être et est la présence de diane à
ses côtés au test simplement une autre
époque le fils aîné de la reine et futur
roi en camée une visite de trois jours
elle s'inscrit dans le cadre du jubilé
de platine les 70 ans de règne
d'elizabeth deux écoutants le prince
charles aujourd'hui à terre neuve et
labrador
on ne sommes visiblement ils étaient
tous
les recours
[Musique]
cette visite pour poser la question que
plusieurs se posent la monarchie at elle
encore sa place au canada et c'est le
cas de s'en affranchir voici la réponse
de justin trudeau
on me disait sur forte au canada on a
une démocratie très forte et un moment
où justement on voit la démocratie sous
attaque littéralement en ukraine mais
aussi des disques universal nous
incitions démocratique à travers le
monde c'est un moment pour à pour savoir
pour être très content qu'on ait un
système très solide au canada est prêt à
nommer plus grande préoccupation c'est
le coût de la vie les changements
climatiques des changements
constitutionnels il n'y a pas énormément
de gens qui m'en parlent régulièrement
mon invité benoît pelletier professeur
de droit constitutionnel à l'université
d'ottawa bonsoir benoît pety
gossement alors la question n'est
certainement pas de nouvelles pour vous
à chaque visite elle se pose parce que
au fond est de moins en moins de
canadiens qui favorise le maintien de la
monarchie
constitutionnelle êtes vous surpris par
le peu de soutien que reçoit la
monarchie
en fait c'est difficile à évaluer parce
que ce sera vraiment au moment du décès
de sa majesté elizabeth ii qu'on saura
si au canada se développe ou non un
vaste mouvement en faveur de l'abolition
de la monarchie tant qu'elle est belle
2e et rennes étant donnée sa sa
popularité étant donnée sa prestance et
sa dignité il ya moins de gens qui sont
favorables à l'abolition de la monarchie
que peut-être bien le verra au moment
sur dix parce qu'on voit un tableau
pendant qu'on se parle ou un pays si
vous voyez vous cette grande majorité
qui qui répondaient déjà tout quand même
un certain sans surprise peut-être pour
vous le québec reçoit lé le plus faible
depuis la plus forte majorité pour
l'abolition au canada ces 26 oui contre
51 et vous avez raison de dire parce
qu'ils aient bête de a écrit l'histoire
depuis quoi
étaient soixante dix ans de règne alors
c'est beaucoup par contre beaucoup de
poids mini c'est le signal est conscient
que le québec refuse toujours donc est
ce que ça sera un choix basé sur les
personnalités ou l'opportunité de
changer de régime politique selon vous
je crois que ce serait un choix fondés
sur l'opportunité l'occasion à quelque
sorte qu'ils se présenteraient
je crois que charles va gagner en
popularité au cours des prochaines
années donc je ne pense pas que ça va
être un choix personnels des canadiens
mais vous savez cela barman à mieux
faire la monarchie viana le canada pour
en faire de même éventuellement et et
quelque sorte la question qui va se
poser si jamais les gens sont favorables
à l'abolition c'est par quel procès par
quel processus par quel plutôt système
on remplacerait la monarchie
concessionnels au canada parce que nous
avons un parlementarisme de type
britannique qui s'accommode très bien
pour dire le moins de la présence d'un
souverain ou du souverain alors donc il
va vraiment falloir réfléchir aussi au
modèle de remplacement est ce qu on
pourrait d'abord une première question
parce que vous savez il n'ya pas
beaucoup d'amoureux de débat
constitutionnel ne vous en déplaise cher
benoît voulu cautionner liste
impressionné de constitution on sent
qu'il ya pas de volonté et les règles
cautionnait les 6 races et exigeantes
pour arriver à un amendement qui
permettrait une transition des
institutions et ça c'est pas demain la
veille que ça va se produire mais ne
propose pas avec justin trudeau
ben non on pu le penser mais en même
temps vous savez si la population vote
d'un câble de référendum mino vers
l'abolition de la monarchie je vois mal
les politiciens se reposer ou les
résister finalement mais qui ferait
référence à
un autre mot un référendum serait le
coup d'envoi à une modification
professionnels et même une réforme
personnel mais de portée limitée ce pas
c'est sûr qu'on ne peut pas revenir à
mitch prend pas on peut pas revenir sur
la table non plus mais s'il y avait une
modification concerne de portée limitée
mais néanmoins substantiels comme le
voudrait l'abolition de la monarchie à
ce moment là les gens pourraient donner
le signal aux politiciens dans les
lettres alors évidemment justin trudeau
est le premier chef de gouvernement
la gouverneure générale qui représente
la reine et la chef d'état la barbade
vous l'avez évoqué mais d'autres que
laisser la monarchie il y en a d'autres
qui veulent atteindre qui veut laisser
la monarchie est ce que on peut garder
un système parlementaire basée sur les
principes de responsables ministériels
un peu les britanniques et avoir un chef
d'état où elle cherche de gouvernement
que chef d'état ça peut être la même
personne
en fait je vous dirais que c'est
possible mais il faudrait connaît en ce
moment là un président une président
d'une république alors
plutôt qu'un souverain désigné par
l'hérédité
on a un président en président il ya des
gens qui me gêne des formules
intermédiaires à titre d'exemple
j'imagine que les fonctions du
gouverneur général pour être assumé par
le juge en chef la juge en chef de la
cour suprême du canada pour le même pour
les provinces ce serait le juge en chef
le juge en chef de la cour d'appel de la
province mais ça ça pose un problème
selon moi en vertu du principe de la
séparation des pouvoirs
lorsqu'il ya des moments dans notre
histoire qui se sont présentés peuvent
se présenter dans l'avenir ou le rôle du
monarque n'est pas que symbolique le
monarque a vraiment un choix à faire en
fonction des règles des conventions
construire l également la légitimité
politique et je vois mal moi un jugement
cher pour une jeune chef a sué de telles
fonctions web en plus un juge en chef à
beaucoup d'autres choses à faire que de
s'occuper de ce que fait normalement un
chef détails beaucoup de protocoles
beaucoup de deux représentations de
l'état est seul juge en chef il ya
d'autres choses à faire que ça cela dit
parlons quand même des relations avec
les autochtones parce que c'est en cause
les traiter avec la couronne britannique
prince est ici aussi pour avoir des
échanges on le vit d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui avec des autochtones dans ce
contexte les pensionnats autochtones
font font font la une au fond tu peux
beaucoup beaucoup les communautés
qu'est-ce qui rêveraient de ces traités
les traités resterait en place et allait
vraiment
subir une continuité en ce qui concerne
la gouverne de l'état une continuité
absolument complète vous savez déjà
langue est un facteur qui est
intéressant à noter c'est que il ya une
le concept d'état en tant que tel et un
poste qui est presque absent en droit
constitutionnel britannique ce e ce à
quoi ils font référence la plupart du
temps c'est à la couronne en terminale
le concept d'état est beaucoup plus
familier à ceux qui ont une culture
française dix ans mais elle reste pas
moins que la couronne représente l'état
l'état en même temps se transpose dans
la corogne à une scierie dire une
interconnexion entre ces deux concepts
et ce même si la couronne devrait
disparaître l'état lui restera bien
entendu
l'appel c'est merci beaucoup
pendant qu'on vous parle on voit l'avion
du prince et de la duchesse de
cornouailles à tahoua il devrait quitter
l'avion d'un instant à l'autre mais on
va quand même se laisser là dessus parce
que de toute façon demain on
on couvrira en direct les différents
événements auxquels le prince va
participer merci beaucoup benoît
pelletier
se fait plaisir à voir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit